and need for the
planning in any project or any
initiatives what we take up
so now project as part of this project
planning we would be trying to
understand what is
uh project planning
project planning fundamentals
then why project planning
tools for project planning
and then basic project planning steps
so let us look at a case a scenario what
happens if there is no planning in place
right
so
[Music]
if you look at the scenario where
one of the
executives in the organization who is in
the project is tensed
and what is the reason the person is
intense if you go and query that acquire
that person
so he says have issues in estimating the
budget
now when we say planning uh planning is
not just about budget planning is beyond
budget
so which involves uh many things like uh
schedule that which is time
the scope which means the deliverables
as well as the resources and other
things what we need to do the project
and to the and to understand what is the
deliverables in requirement perspective
similarly we speak about quality we
speak about risk we speak about
stakeholders procurement
so likewise the planning is bigger than
just a budget but however in this case
we are just looking at a scenario where
estimating the budget has become an
issue
so what could be the reason that has
become an issue
right that might be because
you haven't planned for project properly
so which requires a detailed
understanding or proper understanding of
whatever we are doing
so
so let me tell you how you can make sure
it doesn't happen again with the help of
project planning this is what the
response from experienced personal in
the organization who is into pmo or who
is into project management practices on
regular basis who has a significant
amount of experience so that is the
reason he could able to
point out let us look at the planning so
only then we can able to
have a proper understanding about what
needs to be done and what is there
exactly we need to focus on
so now what is project planning
now when we look at a project as a whole
when you visualize project as a whole
planning is one of the important
part
now if i look at pmi's uh
framework uh we speak about 49 project
management processes
till pmbok sixth edition it was defined
so now out of 49 processes 24 processes
are dedicated for planning which means
almost 50 percent of the processes
are there for planning and that is the
only
area where you have the processes in all
the knowledge areas so we speak about 10
knowledge areas like integration
then scope management
then
cost management schedule management risk
management quality management
communication management stakeholder
management procurement management
resource management
so in each of these knowledge areas we
have the processes when it comes to
planning but when i say i'm going to
initiate the project i'm going to
execute the project i don't see
processes in all the
knowledge areas and it has its own
reason we will not get into that
however the important point what we need
to have an understanding is planning
plays such a significant and important
role
where
majority of the clarity you obtain
you have to obtain during the planning
so we will have this confusion so when i
go with the detailed planning of
something
i may end up in having some changes in
between
means
whenever there is an uncertainty in the
project uncertainty is huge
now there you cannot have a detailed
planning for entire project but you may
require to have the detailed planning
for the extent it is visible to you to
the extent it is clearly visible to
visible to you as a project manager then
you can able to execute that part of it
and get into elaborating further
and then understand the next part of the
project if you are going as as agile way
of doing the projects
but however in either of the cases
whether you are going with predictive
approach of the project
or you are going with the adaptive
approach of the project in either cases
planning is must and it plays very
important role so many a times
we only look at the deliverables part of
it you only look at some processes
relating to executing part of it
we miss out in terms of risk we miss out
in terms of quality
uh maybe we miss out in terms of
analyzing on the effort and resources so
these will actually create issues as you
progress in the project and you may find
difficult in taking the project
to the directions required to the
objective what needs to be accomplished
so first thing we should have a clarity
is
any project when organization takes up
organization takes up the project for a
reason
maybe because of solving certain problem
or improving or enhancing certain
performances or enhancing certain
features functionalities in the project
in the particular product or services
or wanted to introduce some new product
or services into the market likewise
there are many reasons organization
would have to take up the project
and when organization takes up the
project we should keep in mind
organization takes up the project for a
reason
business reason
now as a project manager i need not
worry about revenue but i may require to
have a proper understanding of why the
project is taken up what is the reason
the project is taken up and what is that
organization is trying to accomplish out
of it when as a project manager i have
the clarity
it helps me to take the project in a
specific direction so we may not have
any we should not have any
ambiguity or not having the clarity
instead as a project manager one has to
obtain the clarity and to that context
to accomplish to have everything set
aligned to the directions we were
required to plan so everything we do in
the project should be aligned to what we
are doing however in planning everything
should be visible must only then you can
able to bring that alignment if it is
not available during the planning if we
don't
if we are not considered during the
planning then obviously we may find
difficult in
taking things into that required
alignment or accomplishing that
objective because your execution will be
based on your planning and all that you
monitor and control will be based on
what is defined during the planning
similarly
when you close before closure you test
check whether everything is accomplished
again that is what is defined in the
planning we may have something defined
uh before
project is taken up but the
justification happens there for sure
but for aligning to that you do planning
so everything should be in line and what
intent organization wanted to accomplish
that needs to be achieved and that
requires a proper planning so looking at
a project in entirety right in a project
in entirety a project may have multiple
stages or phases project may have
multiple packages to deliver project
will have multiple developers
so each of these would consider
initiating planning executing monitoring
and controlling and closure
now at each level so if i look at a
project level yes definitely it is there
if i look at the stage or phase level
yes it is there if you look at a
specific deliverables yes it is there at
every level we plan
so since our interest our focus of this
particular session is to look at the
importance of planning project planning
let us focus on planning part of it but
however i will give you some overview
of the frame of project management
framework how it would look like so when
i say initiate what should i initiate so
initially the initiation happens from
business itself as i mentioned already
for accomplishing certain objectives
through that trigger project is taken up
a business case would be created
a project charter will be created and
that project charter will be handed over
to the project manager
while creating this project charter that
would be
considering all those details which is
mentioned in the agreement or the
business case and then that will provide
an entire summary of the project what
needs to be accomplished what is that
organization aiming is aiming to
accomplish through this project
so having that clarity project manager
would take up and connect with
stakeholders and then identify all the
stakeholders
discuss with them bring in smes
have a team structure
and then create a
detailed planning if it is predictive
or a skeleton plan if it is agile
approach
i mean adaptive kind of thing so once
the planning is done
it's all about execution so as a project
manager
the project manager as an individual may
not be doing the hands-on of that
particular
project execution however
the project manager would be involved
actively in terms of ensuring
all those resources are available all
those processes are complied with
then all the stakeholders are connected
updated deliverables are happening as
per the plan so project managers should
see that it is happening and get that
things done
so
in many project management session i
keeps telling people keep asking me this
question specifically the project
manager should have a subject matter
expertise
answer is yes not to the extent where
project manager will go sit and do the
configuration but however
project manager should know what
question to ask what exactly the team is
speaking about
project manager should be able to
visualize that so meaning project
manager should do the groundwork
uh immediately while
you get into planning so as you get in
planning do the groundwork understand
that in entirety
understand from the smes understand from
the industry experts or you do your own
groundwork to know what exactly it is
speak to business and then only then
during the execution you know exactly
what is that output can be expected
and accordingly you do monitoring and
controlling
so from execution to monitoring and
controlling so why we do monitoring and
controlling so as the deliverables comes
out as the features has been introduced
so there should be metrics to measure
there should be methods to measure those
metrics
and each of those metrics critical
success factors or key performance
indicators
uh one should be able to analyze and
understand interpret
so it should not look like just a number
i'm working to accomplish that number it
should not look like that
so accomplishing that number should
result in accomplishing the intended
objective
so that is a kind of uh
understanding team should also have so
through monitoring and controlling one
should align the entire thing by giving
that picture snapshot how things are
going in execution
so which project manager should actively
involve here as well to understand but
this is based on what is being planned
then once it is confirmed everything is
accomplished or achieved according to
the plan then that can be declared for
closing further it can be an acceptance
so without having any confirmation in
monitoring and controlling that
everything is accomplished
things cannot move towards closure
so once it is
done in monitoring and controlling once
the validation is done then only
the acceptance can happen so once the
acceptance is done formality of handing
governing and handing over the product
or feature
putting into production
having formal sign off from the
customers happens in closure
but acceptance
uh in terms of features delivered or it
is according to what we have planned
those are checked in monitoring and
control and formalized in closure
so let us move towards planning what
exactly happens in planning so we get
into defining objectives
so explaining the scope
now speaking about defining objectives
and explaining scope
now uh sorry so now uh
i told business has taken up a project
with an intent
that will have a direction now to
accomplish that particular objective the
planning should have its own set of
objectives considered
to allow in alignment with the objective
what is different is the context the
direction what is set so those
objectives should be clear to the team
it is not just about defining those
needs to be explained to the team so
team should be uh well aware of what
exactly they are going to accomplish by
doing this
then explaining the scope
now scope when you say
one should visualize
both the deliverable as well as what i
should do to deliver it for example if i
am
making a pot for example a clay pot a
clay pot i would be
having certain shape
size color thickness of the wall of that
clear pot so this is the specification
of pot
that is the output that is a deliverable
and that itself will have the scope so
clay pot will have the scope
and to accomplish that clay pot as an
output i need the clay mix i need to
have that wheel which is used i need to
have a person who know that pottery
activity to make that pot
and all that
resources materials what is required to
do it now one is the scope of that
output itself which you can call it as
product scope other one is scope of the
activities the processes the resources
what we do
so the scope of output we can call it as
a product scope and the scope of what we
want to accomplish that results we can
call it as project scope
so we cannot go other way around we
cannot define the project scope and say
that i am going to accomplish this
deliverable no
so first we need to understand what is
the output what is that requirement we
are going to fulfill
have the clarity
have the description how the picture how
exactly it looks likes once it is
completed
and then you come back and define what
process i need to do this what resources
i need
and what effort i require what budget i
need who are the stakeholders for this
all the picture will come only when you
have the clarity about what is that i am
going to deliver from the project so
product scope as well as project scope
then scheduling task
now
i said project scope
product scope we understood what is to
be delivered
now project scope when i say
we have a set of activities we have a
set of resources
we need the budget we need to have an
involvement of stakeholders now all of
these should happen at a specific point
in time everything cannot be done in a
specific one time right so it needs to
be sequenced
it has to be understood what kind of
sequence it is
so how am i going to
do this when am i doing going to do this
when is very important
so
each of this activity what i need to
carry out to accomplish that
particular results i need to have the
schedule defined clearly
so when
so some activities may happen in
parallel some happen in sequence for
example if i take a wall in a
construction project if i take a wall
after doing the plastering of the wall
only i can do the curing
i cannot do the
wall finishing as well as curing of the
same wall at the same time it cannot be
in parallel
whereas i can construct a wall one
meanwhile parallel i can have a
construction of other wall or curing of
other wall i can do but all wall a if i
say
the plastic of that wall and curing the
top wall i cannot change the sequence
it should be in sequence only whereas
parallel if i am constructing another
wall on the other side and clearing that
is possible
which can be done in parallel
so that we need to visualize when we
schedule
when we set that sequencing of that
activities we am required to have a
proper understanding of that
that is about scheduling uh tasks or
activities
then generating progress reports
now it is very important anything and
everything we do we may require to
capture
we may require to analyze we may require
to review we may require to see what can
be improved we might require to look at
what can be optimized
and we need to understand what is going
good what is not going good
how can we uh overcome that something
which is
not going good how can we further
improve on what is that we are doing
good so we need to analyze that so for
that first and most is to understand
how is it now
we
wanted to have this to happen in certain
way
is it happening that way
or is it happening in something some
other way what is that exactly it is
happening so we might require to capture
the details so
while planning i said we might require
to consider critical success factors key
performance indicators metrics to
measure
but we should know what does this matrix
mean
how am i going to analyze this
so if i say
80 percent of utilization means what
what is my interpretation should i keep
quiet or should i do something about it
we should understand that so now i am
supposed to accomplish something in 25
minutes i did that in 30 minutes what
does it signifies five minutes extra i
took is it okay
so it depends on what deliverable what
activity how important is the
deliverable so that understanding should
have so those things has to be analyzed
by
capturing those details as a report and
reviewing that significantly
thoroughly along with the team as well
as the stakeholders relevant
stakeholders
and then the way you represent that
particular report may have the variation
because
when i use that metrics to discuss and
review with the team
the objective will be different whereas
when i do it with
my boss or my customer or some other
stakeholder the objective may be
different what they want will be
different
so i cannot
get into the detail what i discuss with
the team similar details i cannot
discuss with the
other stakeholders it depends who are
the stakeholders with whom i am going to
discuss this and what is that i am going
to present and how are we going to
depict this and what exactly we are
going to learn what is that we are going
to do further from this
so project will have a specific
objectives and directions clearly
mentioned
but to take it in the direction and
understanding whether it is in direction
or not or are we required to do some
changes to bring it back if there is a
deviation all this needs to be
the clarity needs to be obtained
now what are those
planning fundamentals we might require
to have clarity in terms of what is that
we need to consider while planning very
clearly
so here uh determining scope cost and
resources
so
the process of scope cost and resources
i said 10 knowledge areas i mentioned
earlier so in that scope cost and
resources definitely three important
areas which helps in estimating time
required to complete the project the
number of people needed and with what
skill set
now this is one tricky thing so now it
is not just about human resource it's
about skill set
now with that skill set again you speak
about to what extent is it at expert
level or the basic or intermediate what
is that exactly to what extent what is
expected of that role
always depends on deliverables what we
need to do right so the understanding of
this
one can have by having the work
breakdown structure
now
many times i have seen whenever this
term of breakdown structure
people straight away get into
writing the list of activities and then
organizing them in certain order
that is not the way to do the work
breakdown structure so now whenever we
start doing work breakdown structure
first thing one needs to focus on is the
on the deliverable
now for example uh
if i take a
bottle as a deliverable
a simple water bottle
now water bottle if as a user if i look
at it it just looked like a plastic one
transparent one with a cap
water filled inside
that's how it looks like for me as i use
it
but for someone who is creating it for
someone who is making it
i need to have certain activities
processes which are required by
occupants resources which are required
to create that bottle right so what does
the bottle
will have as a deliverable it will have
that body right the main bottle body it
will have a cap and along with the cap
there will be a ring which will just uh
use to seal that particular cap
then
it is not plain bottle right so you will
have
a wrapper around it that is another
deliverable if you want to do the
breakdown of this bottle i would say cap
has one part
cap ring has another part maybe body is
another part body wrapper is another
part now further i can have a
description
so cap will have a specific color cap
will have a specific size
right and specific circumference radius
thickness
similarly the capped ring
then water bottle if you take again that
transparency level
kind of material of that bottle and its
specifications the design you want to
have on the bottle it is a ring design
or some s design whatever as you look at
the bottle or a plain one
and then base of the bottle neck of the
water
then comes the wrapper which you put it
across the sticker part of it what is
that the sticker is all about what is
the combination what is the design of
the sticker
so likewise i will break down so bottle
looked very simple
so same thing if i visualize for a car
as an example
so i can say car interiors car exteriors
and intelligence of the car has three
main
parts
breakdown parts similarly then interiors
if i speak about i can speak about under
interiors
the seat
the gear lever the steering
right
the floor
then the dashboard
i can have that breakdown and further on
inside there is a mirror as well right
so if i speak about further if i break
down if i take a seat as an example so
see it has a base it has a back side one
address then the seat mount like is many
things comes up
so i keep breaking down like this until
logically i cannot subdivide now
similarly if i take exteriors i can take
body bonnet then next rear view mirror
outside
likewise i can do intelligence if i take
like engine system or intelligent
ac system likewise i can have the
breakdown let us take a
car rear view mirror as an example if i
break it down further
mirror cab mirror mount mirror glass
right similarly i can speak about mirror
motor
likewise now can i further subdivide
this mirror glass mirror cap i cannot do
so i will stop there
for each of the breakdown items i keep
breaking down to the extent where
logically i cannot subdivide
it doesn't make uh to subdivide further
now what i will do
the work breakdown structure the
technique we call it as decomposition
we do top down as as shown in the
picture here
top top down it is going so now once you
have this top down structure breakdown
structure which we call it as a product
breakdown structure
once i have the product breakdown
structure
then i will go bottom up now
what will i do bottom most item i will
take for example mirror glass i will
take as an example
so what is the thickness of the glass
definitely rear view mirrors are convex
mirrors what is that convex
specification of that mirror
what is that thickness of that mirror
what is the
size and shape of that mirror glass
i'm speaking of about glass only i'm not
having touched about a cab i have not
even touched about motor
till now i'm just speaking about the
glass alone mirror glass alone
and
once i have the specification to that
mirror glass to that i would see what
resource i need for it
what effort is involved to make the
gloves
right and what is the budget
what is the risk involved what is that
quantity i need to make
so all these details i am putting at
that level it's a lower level
then i'll move to the cap i'll speak
about all of this relating to the cap i
do estimation of that
then i'll speak about the mount mirror
mount then i'll speak about the motor
likewise from bottom up i will do it for
every element and keep consolidating
upwards
as i consult it upwards at the ultimate
consolidation level top level
i will have
overall
uh budget i will have overall schedule
or effort
i will have overall resources require
total resource required i will have what
are the activities involved in
consolidation likewise i have a
consolidation approach so once we have
this consolidation we can easily
look at
the effort involved the budget involved
and further we can optimize
so that's where work breakdown structure
is very essential so now whenever i
speak about work breakdown structure a
simple question which comes up
common sense question or the wrong one
asking okay it is very good if i know
what is the deliverable clearly
so in today's environment we are
speaking more and more about
um
adaptive in nature the projects with
adaptive in nature a lot of changes
keeps coming in people speak about
becoming a child etc now what is
happening here how do i create work
breakdown structure
nothing to worry so now if you take an
example of a bank introducing a
mobile app for mobile banking let us
give an assumption
now what happens here
even though there are lot of mobile
banking applications available we are
used to it bank cannot release the
full-fledged product
simply because of the investment
perspective
enabling the bank and consumers to use
that app if you take me as an example
till now i never used the mobile banking
application of
the bank with whom i have the account
they have motivated me many times and
never went i never used it i never
thought of using it i'm using third
party application and integrating
everything
then is it does it mean that i don't
like my banking application banking
application of the bank with whom i have
an account answer is it is not the
answer something like i've never wanted
to test it i did not find time to look
at it
i'm not motivated enough to look at it
the existing one is okay with me kind of
thing
so if that happens the investment of
bank will be based right so they need to
promote motivate their customers to use
the
application and see what kind of
transaction is happening
in that account and only then they can
able to invest further they have to
study take the feedback from their
consumers and then move forward
so there we have the agility changes
keeps coming in prioritization changes
so here as a mobile banking application
i know what
components are involved features and
inward only priorities will be changing
in this case i will not have an issue of
creating work breakdown structure
but in a scenario where i am doing some
research
i am introducing new product to the
market unique new product to the market
which i don't have any clarity how it
will function
but still to some extent i will have the
clarity about the product
so whatever the extent of clarity you
will have you should do this breakdown
so that you can able to
track them so as you bring in new new
features to it where it doesn't uh where
it is not mentioned in the
wbs structure you can keep adding to
this wba structure so that
pictorially you have something in front
of you
so tracking will become simpler and
easier later
so that's about our breakdown structure
[Music]
so identification of problem
right so variety of techniques such as
conducting surveys or meetings are used
to collect information to assess problem
so it's not just about uh problem it's
all about opportunity also
right so
problem management when i said usually
we do proactively we do reactively
so proactive problem management is
always forcing what can happen if i
continue like this as it is what happens
if this happens as what if conditions
will analyze and then we take action
that is proactive problem management
reactively something has occurred to
resolve it will get into that
so in either case in either of the cases
identification of problem is very
important
so
problem resolution can help in terms of
enhancing and boosting something as part
of your organization's functionalities
so within the project there may be
something which needs to be addressed
so this needs to be analyzed so planning
helps in analyzing this proactively you
are not reactive to anything so you are
proactive
a business may be reactive to some
extent in that case also they will can
be proactive in terms of problem
management
so there will be multiple problems
single problem
some problems where you might require to
have an
attention need to be paid immediately
so one interesting part is whenever i
ask someone what is your understanding
about problem
they say issue
they speak about some failure
so they were they find difficult to link
the term problem to actual meaning of
the problem itself
so when i say issue when i say
occurrence of something that we can call
it as an event or issue or incident that
cannot be a problem
so for occurrence of this event for
occurrence of that incident for
occurrence of that issue
there may be certain trigger
root cause that root cause can be called
as problem so that correct understanding
we should have whenever we say
identification of problem
something failed like for example
internet failed in this training that is
not a problem
internet failed means it is an incident
occurred
why internet fade
as i go deeper and try to understand why
it feel
then
we will see the cause
that is the problem that if you address
we can eliminate many
ways improve the availability of the
incident and reduce the number of
incidents related to internet not
available
so that's what the problem is the
problem doesn't come in operations or
business as usual we will find such
things in the project also so to address
the problem sometimes we take up the
project so which we need to have a
proper clarity about what is the problem
we are trying to address
but remember any project what we take up
introduces change to the environment
problem resolution if i say that
resolution itself is a change happening
to the environment
if i bring in a new structure in the
place where it is an empty land then
that new structure is introduced to that
environment likewise every project
introduces change
so in a way a change project management
is change management that we should keep
in mind always
then identification of stakeholders now
as i take up a project
when i have a project charter as a
project manager
i would have a
specific deliverables specific
objectives to accomplish
but who will be there with me
who can give me the proper clarity or
requirement so i need to connect with
stakeholders as a project manager
first
thing foremost thing which i need to do
is to check who are the stakeholders i
need to connect with the stakeholders i
need to identify the stakeholders
initially for the stakeholders fine but
that is not the end identification of
stakeholder is not a one-time job
we need to keep evaluating on the
stakeholders their
impact their influence
and influence of project and impact of
project on stakeholders and this is
repetitive thing
reason being the stakeholders who were
there initially when we actually
started the project
may not be there
various different reasons there may be
resignations
there may be promotions there will be
change of role
as part of that organization's job
rotation role rotation many reasons
so we may require to
keep
identifying the stakeholders
re-evaluating the existence of those
stakeholders and then keep updating our
stakeholder register so who can be
stakeholders stakeholder can be an
organization
stakeholder can be an individual
stakeholder can be a
group of teams anything so who can
influence
impact
directly indirectly get influenced get
impacted directly and indirectly all
these are stakeholders so identify the
stakeholders capture them in the
stakeholder register
look at what is their importance we we
call it as something like
power interest grid what is the power of
a stakeholder what is their interest
relating to this project
for example if i am doing an it project
and if i consider i t head as a
stakeholder
obviously high in power
high interest because project is related
to id
at the same time for this it project if
i have an hr head
high in power
but low interest
if the project is not related to them
for example i am
working on a project to have a network
connectivity from a internet service
provider highland connect connectivity
as part of our
need of organization hr department or hr
is least worried about it because their
objective is totally different
their focus will be in a different
direction altogether but high in power
how to engage with hr head how to engage
with i.t head
that i can define best of is power and
interest
so we we have something called power
interest rate which can be used to put
the stakeholders in each of the grid
part and see
how do we engage
so that is very important this may keep
changing based on the position changes
or involvement of new stakeholders time
to time and then accordingly you need to
keep
having the change of strategies to
engage with that stakeholders
then defining project objectives
so a plan is made keeping in mind the
various expectation of stakeholder
so very important when i say plan please
remember
organization
or customer will have certain
requirement
that will be the scope of the
requirement
to fulfill that requirement you will
have the solution
so solution will have certain
requirements now these solutions to
fulfill the solutions you have the
resources
you have the process you have the
facility that is the set of requirements
you will have
likewise requirement is of various
different layers
and this requires a specific alignment
similarly you will have a requirement at
a stakeholders level so unless you
understand and how they connect with
each other
if you do not have the clarity you
cannot bring that alignment required
so that needs to be analyzed carefully
so the successor project entirely
depends on how much of expectation can
the project meet
so
by default expectation is achieving 100
percent
accomplishing the expectation 100
percent
that's where you see the success of the
project
but many times the project may not
achieve everything
various different reasons
but you as a project manager should not
aim for not achieving everything if
something is going out of the hand which
you cannot control organization cannot
control
definitely a project manager will be in
touch with project board or sponsor
they are unable to help you in bringing
things under control obviously it means
it is out of control from the system
itself so such things you cannot do
anything like business acquisition
or
you may have some disaster scenarios
many such things comes up because of
which
project may not complete as per the
intent what you have
you will not accomplish those
it may close prematurely
however
which is in your control you should know
and you should move towards the
direction what is required to accomplish
the project and that needs to be updated
to the project board or project
sponsor or pmo whoever is the project
governance authority
a project manager should have a good
handshake with them on a regular basis
under review with the team always
right only then you can able to achieve
that objectives
and
whatever you plan should consider all of
this
so here we speak about risk
right so if something gets deviated why
it will deviate like power failure in
this training i told
what power may fail that is risk
so when we run this session if power
fails or internet fails
are we ready to handle it yes to some
extent okay power goes off
i have the ups
i may say my laptop has the battery
but laptop has the battery but what
about internet
internet the system should need the
power so obviously we need to have a new
ps what if ups fails
can you work beyond that i don't think
so we should work beyond that
uh
that risk remains but probability of
such occurrence is very less
right so that we need to analyze
similarly if you speak about uh
something which we accomplish as part of
this session the object is what we need
to accomplish
we were not able to accomplish a daunted
person that uncertainty remains
so to what extent we can able to
accomplish it what efforts we are
required to put to accomplish it that's
what we need to analyze and then
move forward and be ready for it
all right
now till now we spoke about what is uh
need of project planning and what are
the life cycle in life cycle of a
project what are those involved like
initiation planning execution
monitoring and controlling enclosure
then we spoke about some fundamentals of
project planning
now why project plan
let us look at that
so
with proper planning
it will help us in terms of reducing
cost and time instead of saying reducing
cost and time i would say optimizing
cost and time
so by monitoring and then ensuring that
things are under control as we progress
so project by planning helps us to
accomplish that
increase employee satisfaction
this is one important thing so we keep
hearing this
happy employee means happy customer
how many times
have you heard about it but in reality
is it true
now why do we say happy employee means
happy customer
a satisfied employee will have more
tendency to contribute to organization
and its success so how do you keep
employees satisfied it is very
subjective
but while doing the planning you may
require to ensure
to fulfill or satisfy the need of the
stakeholders involved
so
is one important stakeholder when i have
never taken up a project
can i have all the employees of
organization satisfied the answer is no
then who is that employee we are
referring to maybe like users who are
going to use this particular product or
service
the team members whosoever is involved
in doing this project
so visualizing them and ensuring those
particular set of stakeholders
are happy
involved
right they contribute and complement to
the project
so focus on engaging team for greater
project performance so unless the team
is motivated you cannot see that they
connect to the users better
so if user's connection is not such uh
not there with the people who are
actually engaged in the project because
as a project manager you may not go and
speak to all the users right so to test
or to implement or something to show
uh to demonstrate etc so they should use
a satisfaction whenever there is a query
from users the team should respond to
them well
for example we took up a project of
moving from windows xp to latest
operating system because windows xp
support was stopped
now users are on ground the team should
go and work with them because the
production will get impacted if we just
take things randomly it has to be
scheduled the schedule should be
communicated a new platform new things
what is coming up there should be
education to the users user enablement
should happen technology is one part for
sure that needs to plan the procurement
has to be planned better and you should
do it
but when there is no proper connect with
the users and the team doesn't connect
when will team connect team should have
clarity teams should have the sense of
accomplishment only then they connect
better
so bringing such uh
what is it engagement with the customers
and users are is very essential
then implementing quality assurance
the quality accuracy should happen as we
go
we use two terminologies like quality
assurance quality control
so quality assurance focuses on
compliance quality assurance focus on
accomplishing the objective of processes
what is told what is mentioned doing it
hundred percent
less deviations of zero deviations
and doing all that required to be done
as per the plan
so since uh planning is if planning
gives the clarity
obviously one should be able to
understand that plan and then take
things forward accordingly
then
reduces project risk
already as i mentioned risk
related means uncertainty
uncertainty of occurrence of something
so
there are many
known things which can happen for
example if i take this training what are
those things which can go wrong
internet may fail
power may fail
laptop may fail
the platform may fail
trainer may become
sick
or
participants may create
noise
right the back backend team is not
supporting in time many things can
happen
the ppt is not coming up properly
the streaming platform is not working
properly
so
all these are uncertainty all these are
working at the moment
but they are uncertain
in what probability let me say five
percent uncertain
are we ready to handle it
so we should make ourselves ready to
handle that uncertainty
so we should
have the mitigation plans we should have
a resolution for it proactively
only then we can able to address it now
when can we can can we have this
visibility as this kind of risks are
there in each of this
thing what we are doing
through experience with the involvement
of smes with the involvement of someone
who has actually
experienced this journey they can give
that visibility these type of
occurrences can happen relating to this
and also hypothetically you can come up
with what else can happen like for
example with one of my customers when we
were discussing
we were supposed to take over the entire
operations from the existing service
provider
so customer came up with one uh
interesting uh thought
what if the existing uh
service provider
moves away in hostile way
so they declare from tomorrow we are not
going to support what will you do
are you ready to take over that from
tomorrow itself what is your readiness
that's very interesting though
probability is very less lesser than one
percent
but the business interest of the entity
is engaged with with the
brand value what they want to establish
nobody will pull out just like that but
however
we cannot ignore that query what
customer had so we mean we give the
sufficient explanation of our readiness
hostile exit
this is an interesting thing many times
you will have this from the employees if
not the service provider many of your
team members can have that hostile
exit they would have like absconding
scenarios how do you handle that what if
your sme is absconding
or what if someone where is supposed to
deliver one important thing maybe not a
significant sme but the deliverable
perspective the availability of the team
members are very important but they
they're not available what will you do
so now these kind of risk factors which
needs to be looked at when i say risk
the uncertainty not just negative always
risk by default we call it as uncertain
uncertainty with certain probability of
occurrence and impact
but
risk doesn't mean only negative
it can be positive also
what can be positive risk
i i can have a overwhelming results i
thought it will achieve 100 percent it
went beyond that
very nice though so like for example
covet 19 pandemic scenario
we thought our productivity would reduce
because everything is working from home
instead productivity increased
earlier it used to be around 70 percent
has become 120 percent
possible that is positive risk
so uncertainty what in what perspective
in what
what is the chance in what probability
it can become
an improvement in terms of productivity
when people go working from home i don't
know
maybe i would say two percent possible
probability
it can happen so any uncertainty is risk
it is positive it is negative but we
will have a tendency to look at the
negative part of it because it will have
an impact it will pull away us from
what we are supposed to accomplish that
is the reason we look at negative risk
and analyze them
regularly as i spoke about stakeholder
register here also you are required to
establish risk register
but again it is dynamic document if as
you progress in the project life cycle
new risks will get introduced many risks
what you identified initially
may not be there the probability of that
impact number may go off
so likewise new risks will get
introduced existing risk may have a
different kind of impacts kind of thing
power failure if i take an example as a
risk for this training
what if power failed when i started the
session
entire session is gone impact
what if it goes off at the last five
minutes of the session negligible impact
occurrence is same power going off but
when it occurs the proximity of
occurrence also matters so likewise we
are required to keep evaluating the
risks throughout the project life cycle
identify new risk add it to the list and
then analyze them regularly throughout
the project life cycle that is very
important then tools for project
planning
so
definitely we record have a set of tools
while we plan like wbs thing what we saw
earlier
likewise many tools and techniques we
need
as we go through the planning one is
gantt chart
so gantt chart we use it for
having a
visibly represented schedule
right so
i think any tool if you see today
including excel sheet i'm telling so as
an ms project or primavera
or
the google project sheet or excel sheet
any kind of project management
practices if you see you will see the
visual representation like the anchor
so gantt chart is one type of view other
one is
we can think about
network diagram view
so once you establish a gantt chart you
can have a network diagram view which
will show you
when the activity is going to start what
is the sequence of the activity
and
how they are connected each of the
activities with the dates with the
resources with the activity what needs
to be accomplished
with the color combination you can say
that when it is starting when it is
ending like similarly we have a critical
path method
where you have a
tool determining each of the activities
and critical path means in a given
diagram network diagram
the longest path is called as critical
path
so the duration of the longest path of
the network diagram
will be the duration of the project so
why do we call that as a critical path
we call it as a critical path because
any delay in the critical path will
delay the project itself
any delay in the critical path
will delay the project itself that is
the reason we call it as critical path
method
so
another one we have like critical chain
method
so a critical activities which are
essential for
accomplishing the required results which
has to be looked at very carefully see
if something delays there will delay the
project
so critical path method is crucial tool
for determining the progress of project
so that project is on schedule
right so longest path and delay in the
critical path will delay the project
so
similarly we have a
per chart we part refers to program
evaluation review techniques
which will help in analyzing the task to
complete the project and time required
to
complete those tasks we called as three
point estimation by analyzing this
optimistic pessimistic most likely
estimates and accordingly what would be
the estimate of the duration right which
we'll use in terms of planning
then work breakdown structure i guess we
went through it in detail already
so we do decomposition top down and do
product breakdown first and then we go
bottom up adding budget resources
schedules efforts then
resources required
then how long it takes in what sequence
sequencing can happen after having the
work breakdown structure like we said
critical path method or gantt chart
sequencing
those we can do only after work program
structure
then project documentation now project
documentation starts from the point
where
you create a project charter before that
there is a documentation documentation
in terms of agreements documentation in
terms of business case
many such documents which are referred
while creating a project charter project
charter will become a first document
handed over to the project manager
from then project manager would go
create the stakeholder register then
scope documents
then risk documents
budget part of it schedule part of it
then risk quality
procurement related to contracts and
agreements
then register required to all of this
the stakeholder register
like as many documents which are created
then referred
updated throughout the project life
cycle so which are very essential now
when i mean something called agile
manifesto we may come across it says
one of the manifesto points says
deliverables
delivering the features
over documentation
now
does it mean that we're ignoring
documentation answer is no comprehensive
documentation that's what the word it
shows we need documentation
extent to the extent what is required
for that scenario if it is adaptive
obviously the minimum document or
documentation required as we progress we
can keep updating that and consolidate
it whereas a predictive obviously end to
end view anywhere you will have so you
can create a comprehensive documentation
in one go so why do we not do
full-fledged comprehensive documentation
in adaptive simply because any changes
comes up
so we'll have a lot of changes to be
done in the documentation also which
will become tdsx
but we are not ignoring documentation
all right so project documents helps in
ah
capturing what is that actually done and
what is that we have planned did we
really accomplish and it will also
become evidence to prove that we have
done it
so very important
so basic project planning steps would
involve
like identifying and meeting the
stakeholders
defining scope
then setting and prioritizing objectives
determining deliverables then create
project schedule risk analysis
set progress reporting guidelines
now this
flow typically looks like
linear
so identify and meet stakeholders means
you are connected with stakeholders you
are understanding the requirements and
then elaborating on the school
understanding
then you keep that prioritization give
that
importance what is that first we need to
do what is next you should have that
sequence
then you get into uh determining what
exactly the deliverable is to accomplish
it
and as you have the sequence
work breakdown structures happens here
determining deliverables kind of thing
and the sequencing happens
but it comes to create project schedules
and each of that you may bring over the
risk analysis for all the constraints
constraint should be scope
schedule cost resource risk quality
so you look at the risk associated with
all of this and then i have a metrics
for all of this and then have a progress
report as we mentioned and this should
be regular thing
so identifying mid stakeholders happens
in during the initiation part of it
first step
is to identify the stakeholders and
understanding their
expectation explain that earlier in the
flow as well
then you will define scope
so project scope involves determining
the list of
specific project goals deliverables
budgets and deadlines then the project
scope helps in establishing boundaries
of project and responsibility of each
team member
then you will go set and prioritize
objectives
so objectives are set prioritize once
the expectation of stakeholders become
certain
means you you are clear now what is the
exact expectation of stakeholders so
this step finer detail to the initial
ideas is set that serves as a reference
point
all through the project
so then determining deliverables so
deliverables are the reasons why
projects are created it is one of the
most important steps to understand those
deliverables
so project planning steps of the project
when you determine what these
deliverables will be and how will
they be delivered in time
then you create project schedule
which has an outline of different tasks
of a project
are supposed to begin and end
so remember project will have a
beginning and end
the very definition of project itself
says
project starts
project is temporary in nature the
definition of project itself is
temporarily and over so it has a
beginning it has the end it may be for
months it may be for some many number of
years doesn't matter
definitely there is a beginning there is
end for a project
which creates a unique output
so project schedule helps in measuring
project progress and setting up the
project
progress reports
risk analysis
so one needs to identify risks and
considering steps to deal with it is
important step of project planning
steps to prevent risk from happening or
limiting the impact should be
considered
next set progress reporting guidelines
there must be a communication plan to
update the stakeholders
regarding the project progress this can
be done monthly weekly or daily so that
all involved members can monitor the
progress
and why is it very important we
discussed about in detail earlier
and that needs to be done on a regular
basis and one should have a clarity how
the project is progressing
very clear
so i think as this explanation comes up
i guess
it is very clear
one can able to plan the projects within
the budget and
do the things better to achieve
accommodation quality that's what he is
expressing
thanks for explanation now i will be
able to plan projects within budget and
of better quality
right and that's all from mind today
about uh project planning and its
importance
hope you had a good session
uh feel free to post your questions in
the
chat
in the chat so also you can contact us
visiting www.simplen.com
and
let us know what you
like to see further
take care all the best